bonjour Marie Zalo bonjour
député des Landes présidents du groupe
socialiste à l'Assemblée nationale on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Christelle
Berton du groupe La Dépêche bonjour
Christelle bonjour Oriane bonjour
d'actualités à voir avec vous Boris
vallon on commence par cette motion de
censure qui a donc été rejeté par
l'ensemble de l'Assemblée nationale en
tout cas pas adopté le gouvernement n'a
pas été renversé mais le rassemblement
national a fait le choix à la surprise
un peu général de voter la motion de
censure de la gauche de la nuque est-ce
que vous regrettez que le rassemblement
national est voté avec vous
je combats rassemblement national tous
les jours dans l'hémicycle et dès le
premier jour dans ma réponse à Elisabeth
borne dans son discours de politique
générale j'ai mis les points sur les i
il y a rien de banal à ce que l'extrême
droite dans une enceinte républicaine je
les redis d'ailleurs au moment de
défendre la motion de censure que tous
nous séparait comme socialistes comme
de gauche et comme républicain de
l'extrême droite donc je le dis
évidemment avec netteté et que le RN ne
vote pas cette motion de censure
pas et elle l'avait dit d'ailleurs
qu'elle ne le voterait pas elle avait sa
propre émotion que nous n'avons pas voté
et que les choses soient claires nous ne
voterons jamais une motion de censure de
l'extrême droite comme nous ne votons
pas les amendements qui viennent de nous
n'avons pas voté
dans quelques que ce soit pour les
désigner à la vice-président de de
l'Assemblée elle a dit qu'elle a voté
parce qu'elle était présentée en termes
acceptable ce sont ces mots est-ce qu'il
aurait fallu une motion plus résolument
à gauche pour que le reste
identité elle était une résolution de
gauche quand on lit le journal du
lendemain évidemment on sait bien ce
qu'il fait ce qu'il aurait sans doute
fallu faire il faut peut-être vont
durcir les choses je le crois est-ce que
est-ce que c'est un que certains chez
vous regrettent qu'un passage sur
l'immigration par exemple et était
retiré
donc vous savez
il y a des gens qui sont toujours
de bons de bons conseils ils sont
toujours rétrospectivement et qui sont
quand ils sont pas au premier chef
concernés moi je vous le dis j'ai
toujours été intransigeant sur ce sujet
là et je continuerai de l'aide parce que
il y a pas d'ambiguïté tout nous
distingue tous nous distinguer voilà
mais est-ce que tout le monde l'était au
sein de la nuque en clair est-ce qu'il y
a eu des divergences entre vous et la
France la question qui s'est posée c'est
parce qu'il y avait eu un député de la
France insoumise qui avait laissé
supposer qu'il y avait des circonstances
des circonstances très particulières
c'est si le gouvernement introduisait la
réforme de l'assurance par amendement ou
il pourrait voter c'est une option
personnelle une
motion de censure de l'extrême droite ce
débat
on l'a eu on l'a eu et on l'a eu en
franchise et les choses ont été
clarifiées et d'ailleurs vous l'avez vu
personne à gauche n'a voté la motion de
censure de l'extrême droite voilà il y a
cette dit que nous mettons entre eux et
nous et si il vote l'émotion si le vote
nos textes c'est à dire je vois que le
rassemblement national vote les
propositions les amendements que ce soit
de la droite de la gauche de tout le
monde ils sont propriétaires de leur
vote mais je le redis tout nous
distingue et notre vie certains députés
écologistes alors très peu qui n'ont pas
du coup voté la mention voilà pour pas
mêler leur voix à celle du rassemblement
est-ce que vous quand vous avez appris
que le RN allait voter votre émotion
vous avez hésité moi je vous dis c'était
un coup de poing dans le ventre voilà je
vous dis tel que je l'ai ressenti et je
me suis dit finalement est-ce que c'est
le rassemblement national qui doit
décider de mon vote sur mon texte voilà
d'utilisation des instruments qui sont
mis à disposition du Parlement est-ce
que je me réjouis d'abord qu'il y a eu
la nécessité d'une motion de censure
parce que revenons quand même un tout
petit peu aux
on était en train de débattre d'une loi
de finances composée de 26 articles il y
a eu quatre articles d'examinés quatre
articles d'examinés et je vous assure le
débat a été serein il y a eu pas eu
d'obstruction nous avons à gauche nous
avons à gauche
que le groupe Renaissance et le groupe
de la majorité il y a d'ailleurs sous
les yeux parfois
plein de reproches de du gouvernement
des accords qui se sont qui se sont
noués autour d'amendement qui nous
paraissaient de bon sens je pense à
celui de Jean-Paul mettei qui est le
président du groupe modem sur les hyper
dividendes et puis il y a des débats de
fonds qui se sont construits des
désaccords qui se sont exprimés mais à
un moment donné le gouvernement a
interrompu de façon prématurée il n'en
est pas l'obligation il y a d'autres
mesures dans les lois organiques qui
permettent de prolonger le débat et de
tenir des calendriers la France
réparation revenir à ce texte sur la
notion de censure est-ce que désormais
vous allez être plus vigilant sur la
manière de rédiger les textes afin de ne
pas ouvrir une porte bien sûr et je vais
vous dire c'est le premier jour c'est
une question comment
on est dans cette assemblée avec 89
députés d'extrême droite c'est une
question de chaque instant c'est une
question de chacun son se poser
d'ailleurs très vite quand il a fallu
désigner le bureau de l'Assemblée
nationale avec des testeurs et des
vice-président et toute la gauche a dit
bah nous nous voterons pas pour que soit
désigné des des députés avec elle nous
partageons nous partageons rien ça a pas
été le choix le choix d'autre après moi
je confonds pas tout hein j'ai pas un
train de de d'insulter
telle ou tel député de de la majorité je
dis que ça n'est pas banal et que tout
ce qui doit être entreprises et que ça
ne soit jamais banal on va écouter la
réponse de la majorité en tout cas
Gabriel Attal qui était hier matin
l'invité de France 2 écouter ce qu'il a
dit à propos du vote des députés
socialistes
[Musique]
censure de la dernière législature a
voté celle de
Bruno Le Maire enfin qui avait été signé
et voté par par Bruno Le Maire dans dans
contre la loi Macron bon donc je vous
dis le journal du lendemain on a
toujours plein d'idées
ma position n'a pas varié c'est des
saucisses pas varié nous le disons à la
majorité ils ont à nos partenaires à
gauche
j'allais dire notre ennemi notre
adversaire politique résolu c'est
l'extrême droite et toute les les
valeurs quel véhicule et qui sont à
rebondir notre vous êtes retrouvé hier
entre socialiste et un bureau national
est-ce que ça a fait débat mais bien sûr
que ça fait débat mais heureusement que
les bureaux nationaux du Parti
socialiste sont des lieux de débat sinon
est-ce qu'on en aurait entre nous donc
ça crée des divisions sympas
est-ce que et je veux dire moi j'ai dit
des choses avec netteté comme je le fais
ce matin et la vigilance elle doit
toujours être là et elle doit redoubler
dans certaines circonstances quand vous
lisez Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui dit il
manquait 50 voix pour éjecter le
gouvernement nous sommes prêts pour la
relève ce nouilles vous pose problème
bah écoutez qu'on soit dans le devant le
passé dans la nécessité de construire
une alternative à l'extrême droite parce
que je veux pas que les prochains se
soient eux et à Emmanuel Macron oui
c'est un devoir que que nous avons dans
la fidélité à ce que nous sommes à
gauche voilà et pour ce qui me concerne
comme président du groupe socialiste
parce que je suis comme socialiste avec
une histoire longue comme le groupe le
plus ancien de l'Assemblée nationale 130
ans l'année prochaine et puis pardon ne
réjouit pas aussi de de ce
fonctionnement totalement dysfonctionnel
de l'Assemblée nationale moi j'ai fait
cette page de cette fonctionnelle parce
qu'il y a un parlementarisme de fait
issu des urnes que le gouvernement est
une majorité relative et qui nous faut
apprendre et d'abord le gouvernement
président de la République avait dit il
va falloir apprendre à légiférer
autrement et à gouverner autrement
est-ce qu'il légifère autrement et ce
qui gouverne non il ne le font pas j'ai
fait cette page de proposition on a
repris des amendements des des deux
oppositions 112 amendements je crois de
la majorité et 13 voilà et 17 de des
oppositions et franchement des hochets
faut arrêter la question qui se pose à
nous tous c'est comment on fait marcher
cette Assemblée nationale dans une
configuration qui est un parlementarisme
de fait j'ai fait cette page de
proposition à la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale moi je crois le
compromis le fera sans doute que le
compromis c'est d'abord une méthode ça
peut pas être simplement un ralliement
sinon ça n'existe pas et nous ne
cesserons vous demander le changement
des règles au sein de l'assemblée je
pense que nous devons interroger nos
pratiques que nous devons à cadre
juridique constant on peut changer
changer les choses et peut-être même
légiférer pour légiférer mieux ce que a
été capable quand on était capable des
majoritaires hallucifs dans l'histoire
au Parlement passage à l'acte maintenant
on va parler des super profits oui vous
parliez des super dividendes vous avez
vous souhaitez en référendum
d'initiative populaire sur les super
profits le Conseil constitutionnel a
estimé hier soir que cette demande ne
remplit pas les conditions quel est
votre réaction à ça la réaction c'est
d'abord de la déception évidemment quand
on entreprend une démarche comme un René
ferrandum d'initiative partagée pour que
les Français puissent se prononcer sur
un sujet qui les concerne et je crois
qu'ils appellent de leurs vœux c'est une
déception bon c'est la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel qui pour la
première fois légifère sur un sujet sur
lequel c'est jamais prononcé et la
question c'était de savoir si cette
mesure fiscale pouvait être considérée
comme une mesure de politique économique
nous nous avons nous nous avons les
politiques
je vais pas dire qu'elle est politique
même si évidemment on a toujours posé la
question de du Conseil constitutionnel
et de ça et de ça de ça représentation
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que là il
y a une décision moi j'en prends acte de
cette décision est-ce que on peut
retravailler le texte est-ce que on a
d'autres voies et moyens moi ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que je proposerai à
mes collègues socialistes que dans la
niche parlementaire du groupe socialiste
il y est une proposition de loi sur les
super les super Trophy et je sais que
mes collègues au Sénat puisque j'en ai
parlé avec mes collègues du Sénat j'en
ai parlé très missiro j'en ai parlé que
Patrick canard vont aussi dans le débat
budgétaire qui va bientôt s'ouvrir ici
au Sénat vont pousser cette cette
proposition pourquoi donc vous continuez
le combat donner en donner le sens et
quel était le le sens du débat parce que
celui qui sentir un bon compte c'est
quand même le gouvernement c'est que la
question que nous posions à travers des
recettes supplémentaires sur les
multinationales sur les très riches
c'est qui va payer le quoi qu'il en
coûte est-ce que c'est ce qu'on a
applaudis à 20h les classes populaires
avec classe moyenne ou est-ce qu'un
effort supplémentaire de solidarité
nationale demander à ceux qui le peuvent
va permettre justement
un plus juste fardeau et la réponse du
Verdon c'est on touchera pas à cela mais
en revanche ça doit se faire au niveau
européen pour pas récupérer 200 millions
là où en réalité c'est les milliards
qu'il faudrait qu'il faudrait récupérer
et comment ils répondent à cette
équation que je viens de poser ils
disent bah non on va pas toucher
à l'argent des multinationales et des
hyper riches donc les PME continueront
de payer les impôts des multinationales
qui ne payent pas les classes moyennes
continueront à payer les impôts des très
riches qui n'en payent pas suffisamment
et donc qui va payer bah ce qu'on
applaudi à 20h il y aura moins de droit
au chômage il y aura moins de droit à la
retraite il y aura moins de droit au RSA
et je crois que dans ce que vous avez
dit dans votre discours exactement dans
lequel nous sommes où la vie est
difficile pour les Françaises et les
français pour tous celles et ceux qui
n'ont que leur force de travail pour lui
et qui n'en vivent pas toujours bien si
la question des salaires est aussi été
posée à l'action du l'histoire d'achat a
été posée et bien je crois que il y a
des différences de philosophie mais oui
c'est ça le débat parlementaire c'est ça
qu'il doit nourrir c'est ça quand je
parle du parlementarisme fait autour de
autour de ces questions là de ces
polarités là qu'on doit se poser la
question de savoir si elle est point de
convergence peut-être qu'il y en a pas
peut-être qu'il y en a pas mais enfin
qu'on est des espaces on puisse en
parler alors justement Emmanuel Macron
lui et sur France 2 ce soir pour
répondre à des questions de politique
nationale qu'est-ce que vous attendez de
cette intervention
est-ce que vous attendez des annonces et
lesquelles bah écoutez il y a plusieurs
il y a plusieurs sujets qui aujourd'hui
préoccupent les Françaises et les
Français
il y a d'abord la situation
internationale
et la guerre en Ukraine je souhaite que
le président en parle et qu'il en parle
avec clarté avec net et la France doit
continuer de se tenir au côté du peuple
crânien dans le conflit qui oppose à la
Russie de Vladimir Poutine ça veut dire
que il faut continuer je veux dire qu'il
faut faire plus et mieux il faut
continuer à sanctionner la Russie il
faut sans doute plus de moyens
militaires pour les forces armées
ukrainiennes et puis il faut aussi être
sans ambiguïté sur ce que nous
reconnaissons comme frontières les
frontières de 91 sont les seules
frontières internationalement reconnues
et donc voilà il faut être aux côtés de
des Ukrainiens parce que c'est une
guerre contre l'Ukraine en Europe et
contre l'Europe parce que on voit bien
ce qui se joue c'est les guerres de
modèles politiques et nos politiques
nationales qu'est-ce que vous attendez
[Musique]
il y a la question du pouvoir d'achat
qui me paraît aujourd'hui absolument
impérative les lois pouvoir d'achat au
fond elle était du point de vue des
Français qui ont du mal à joindre les
deux bouts
consommer au moment où elle était
évoquée ils avaient déjà un certain
nombre de difficultés et elle se sont
prolongées il y a le coût d'énergie il y
a le bouclier de tarifaire mais enfin
dans sa nouvelle forme qui pour beaucoup
de classement moyenne va signifier des
surcoutes très importants vous demandez
de nouvelles aides je pense qu'il faut
sans doute mieux cibler et notamment
pour les classes moyennes
ces aides là je pense également que cet
homme de produits de première nécessité
de produits du quotidien de produits
alimentaires qui subissent une inflation
importante doivent aussi être pris en
considération je souhaite que la
question des salaires soit posée voilà
nous nous posons depuis maintenant
plusieurs années la question du partage
de la valeur ajoutée sur ces questions
là la nuit fera organiser une marche
moi je vous parle là comme parlementaire
c'est ce que j'attends du président de
la République ce soir donc moi ce que je
vous dis c'est que la question du
salaire elle est importante du partage
de la valeur ajoutée des écarts de
richesse est-ce que on peut encore
considérer que le patron d'une grande
enseigne la grande distribution gagne
300 fois ce que gagne sa caissière et
puis il y a la situation de nos services
publics et je pense en particulier à
cette situation alarmante de l'hôpital
on a vu et vous l'avez entendu le monde
de la pédiatrie qui s'inquiète parce que
l'épidémie de bronchiolite arrive et qui
n'ont pas suffisamment de moyens pour
prendre en charge il y a une rustine les
enfants qui sont obligés d'être soignés
très loin
de tant mieux 150 millions d'euros mais
on voit bien que
c'est insuffisant dans le débat sur le
PLFSS ce que nous avons dit c'est le
budget de l'hôpital le budget de la
santé est insuffisant le gouvernement
dit mais ces 3,7% on n'a jamais fait
autant oui mais l'inflation n'a jamais
été aussi haute et pour la première fois
depuis toujours le niveau de l'inflation
est supérieur au niveau du budget de la
santé l'augmentation du budget de la
santé ça veut dire que on va l'air réel
des falquets de l'inflation et bien ce
sera une baisse de -0,6% c'est 1,5
milliards d'économies grosso modo alors
comment on fait fonctionner un hôpital
comment on garantit l'accès aux soins
comme on gagne des qualités de vie au
travail d'exercices de la profession
comment on redonne du sens à un hôpital
pour lequel des soignants ont été
tellement mis à rue des preuves que ils
finissent par perdre le goût de leur de
leur travail ben ça j'attends évidemment
le président de la République sur ces
sujets ça me paraît absolument impératif
et ce que vous souhaitez qu'il
interviennent sur la réforme des
retraites qui va être le prochain gros
dossier
oui la réforme des retraites un sujet
important on a été reçu par la première
ministre avec Patrick kaner comme tous
les présidents de groupe ces
concertation c'est informatif
à ce stade je la concertation ce n'est
pas un lieu de concertation non non
aucunement enfin si jamais désagréable
d'être informé je préfère que les choses
nous soient dites en face à face plutôt
que de les apprendre par la presse même
si vous faites votre travail en
l'occurrence mais oui il faut qu'il faut
qu'il en parle parce que quand je parle
de compromis la question se pose d'abord
à cette majorité qui n'a pas de majorité
absolue qui a la plus grosse des
minorités pourrait-on pourrait-on dire à
quoi est-elle prêt à renoncer voilà
c'est ça la question et vous quel est le
compromis que vous êtes prêt à faire sur
ce sujet mais sur la retraite à 65 ans
que le système est retraite actuel soit
à certains égards injustes qu'il puisse
être améliorés c'est une évidence vous
savez on se construit la meilleure des
retraites dans la meilleure des
carrières et donc il faut se poser la
question de du marché du travail du
travail des femmes de l'égalité
salariale une fois encore parce que 20%
de salaires en moins c'est 20% de
cotisations en moins pour notre
assurance chômage et à la fin des
petites retraites des carrières hachées
les carrières interrompues le lien avec
assurance chômage mais selon la question
de la gouvernement vous propose de
retravailler sur la loi Touraine
c'est-à-dire la loi qui augmente
progressivement la durée de cotisation
est-ce que il dit c'est 65 ans voilà il
dit c'est 65 ans nous on dit vous avez
supprimé un certain nombre de critères
de la pénibilité il y a un quart des
Français les plus les plus modestes qui
sont déjà décédés à 62 ans il y a une
question qui est une question de justice
prévention de la pénibilité parce qu'un
certain nombre de métier sont
extrêmement difficiles la prévalence au
cancer par exemple de ceux qui sont
explosés au produit chimiques et bien
plus grandes il y a des métiers qui sont
des métiers pénibles il faut évidemment
travailler là-dessus et faire travailler
sur ces thématiques que sont la
pénibilité derrière nous on demande je
crois que le gouvernement veut le faire
mais parfois il semble le faire mais
plus souvent il fait semblant donc je
veux dire nous on sera extrêmement
exigeant extrêmement vigilant et puis un
certain nombre d'hypothèses sur la
pénibilité sur les carrés donc est-ce
que vous êtes prêt à accepter un recul
de l'âge de départ non je dis sur l'âge
de la retraite non parce que ça n'est
pas la solution et parce que surtout ça
n'est pas juste je le dis ça n'est pas
juste de travailler jusqu'à 65 ans ça
fait des vies ça fait des victimes
est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça signifie sur
la santé qu'est-ce que ça signifie sur
l'emploi designers qu'est-ce que ça
signifie sur l'emploi des jeunes
qu'est-ce que ça signifie sur les
carrières langues tiendront cet âge ils
n'auront pas votre soutien bah non
écoutez on l'a dit avec nete quand même
je crois
qui a été rejeté hier par l'Assemblée
est-ce que vous êtes auto-censuré comme
l'a dit Gabriel Attal sur la loi de
programmation
de Gabriel Attal dans les circonspects
comme formule est-ce qu'on sait auto
censuré je veux dire vous aviez voté des
modifications et en de votant pas le
texte final finalement ces modifications
ne seront pas retenues
oui c'est un fait
simplement cette loi de programmation
d'abord c'est sans conséquence le fait
que elle est pas été adoptée je si ça
devait vous inquiéter je n'en sais rien
je passe en tout cas sur les crédits du
plan de relance notamment et sur
l'attitude Bruxelles vous avez de la
France
on peut pas inquiéter on peut pas
m'inquiéter on peut pas demander à des
gens qui ne sont pas d'accord avec la
réforme de l'assurance chômage et donc
ne met pas dans leur compte les
économies que dans le gouvernements on
attend qui n'est pas d'accord avec la
réforme d'assurance chômage qui donc ne
met pas
compte les 10 milliards d'euros
d'économies que le gouvernement compte
faire qui est contre un certain nombre
de réformes de voilà on a dit aussi des
choses qui sont très simples et c'est
pas inintéressant que les Français le
sachent on a contesté la politique de
gestion de la dette du gouvernement il y
a un problème de crédibilité même de
sérieux budgétaires de la part du
gouvernement à trois reprises et encore
cet été le gouvernement a fait
il les a indexés sur l'inflation
c'est-à-dire qu'on a 11% de nos dettes
de 150 milliards qui est un excès sur
l'inflation franchement fallait pas être
très clairvoyant pour accepter en
réalité de faire des emprunts toxiques
nationaux ça veut dire qu'à chaque fois
qu'il y aura 1 % de plus d'inflation il
y aura 2,5 milliards de charges de la
dette en plus en fait alors que
normalement tout est économiste j'allais
dire est capable de savoir que
l'inflation normalement allège la dette
et ben là le gouvernement réussit le
tour de force de faire autrement
oui le Parti socialiste prépare son
congrès de début 2023 vous attendez à
combien de motions et est-ce que vous
savez déjà qui vous allez soutenir
je vais vous dire d'abord que
c'est les moments de démocratie les
c'est des moments de débat
parfois c'est des moments de
conflictualité et tout ça c'est pas un
problème
au contraire moi je suis toujours
demandeurez l'histoire fummultueuse du
Parti socialiste elle est pas elle est
pas toujours écoutez moi je suis engagé
vous le savez dans cette dans cette
tenue que je ferai valoir aussi un
certain nombre de choses le moment venu
comme président du groupe je dirais je
dirais les choses je dirais aussi ce que
je crois que doit être aussi le chemin
des des années des années à venir et
j'ai un groupe dans lequel il y a je
vais dire à peu près toutes les opinions
moi je suis présent au groupe donc je
m'expliquerai je m'exprimerai le moment
venu donc il y a combien il y aura de
motion je peux vous dire que je n'en
sais rien
lui souhaite une troisième voie il dit
faut une troisième voie entre les jeunes
et Hélène Geoffroy c'est aussi votre
avis
est-ce que j'ai signé la proposition de
de Patrick canaire moi je suis président
groupe aujourd'hui qui j'allais dire
tiens un groupe qui est aujourd'hui
unique une la cohésion qui travaille
ensemble qui ne se préoccupe jamais du
Candy de telle ou tel mais qui se
dit qu'est-ce que je pense moi comme
socialiste sur tous les sujets ce sera
vrai sur la question
énergétique ce sera vrai sur la question
migratoire pour lesquelles on engage un
travail un travail de fond et on
continuera de le faire de le faire comme
ça les élections européennes sont pas en
train par exemple de diviser le groupe
entre ceux qui voudraient qu'une
candidature sans la France insoumise et
ceux qui disent discutons et voyons si
on peut faire une candidature commune
honnêtement je pense qu'on en est
vraiment pas là et le Parti socialiste
lui doit d'abord je pense travailler sur
ce qu'il veut dire au titre de sa
politique européenne qu'est-ce qu'il
veut dire du projet européen en plus de
ça dans des circonstances très
particulières où la question de la
guerre à nos frontières est posée de la
contestation de nos modèles politiques à
l'intérieur de nos frontières est à
l'oeuvre en France mais vous l'avez vu
en Italie et quelque chose d'identitaire
en tout cas notre attachement à l'Europe
il est identitaire sera vachement un
projet européen une construction
européenne est-ce que ça veut dire
n'importe quel Europe moi je veux dire
je me définis comme un euro exigeant pas
un euro Béa et pas un neuroceptique et
l'Europe que et l'Europe que je souhaite
c'est une Europe qui ne soit pas naïve
dans une mondialisation qui est devenue
des égards déloyale qui ne soit pas
naïve dans ses rapports
et qu'elle est une ligne de force on est
capable moi je vais vous dire je
parfois je me dis d'autres il crois
moins que moi mais je crois la force des
idées des idées socialistes j'y crois
tellement fort autant qu'à l'heure
actuelle
que je me dis que ben il faut les
défendre et qu'elles peuvent être
contagieuses voilà c'est ce
que vous avez travaillé avec François
Hollande à l'Elysée comment vous vous
vivez sa prise de parole dans le débat
actuel notamment ses piques à l'égard de
la nuque et d'Olivier fort
je sais pas si je peux faire un
commentaire plus que celui-là non bah
écoutez je
vous avais compris d'une manière
générale j'ai pris l'habitude de pas
commenter les commentaires et d'essayer
de parler de la vie des Françaises et
des Français vous savez moi c'est la
seule chose qui me préoccupe quand je
rentre dans les Landes
toutes les semaines je reçois ma
permanence et j'ai des gens qui ont des
problèmes de logement qui ont des
problèmes de santé
et ils attendent que je leur parle de la
leur merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité à la Une de La Dépêche
disparition du style la piste criminelle
c'est dans le Lot merci beaucoup
Christelle d'avoir été avec nous merci
Boris merci on passe tout de suite au
club des territoires
[Musique]